is that common that we have an  expectation that because Francis or  Brian are good at scientific research  that they're also good at teaching or is  that a mistake you know Dakota school  that exists today at the American  universities in a sense I'm fortunate it  still lives in the days that you take  courses and learn all of physics and  then do research first of all you cannot  learn all of physics anymore you cannot  even learn all about some specialized  subject in physics no so the way  everything I know the Belgian system at  the time allowed you to do this  everything I know I've I've learned by  doing research you get interested in a  problem you have to solve it you learn  everything you need to solve that  problem and that's how you learn and you  remember trying to get a background of  all of physics before you start doing  research is an illusion which we are  still living in in our present system of  graduate schools